we are now less than three weeks away
from apple's rumored march 8th spring
event where they're expected to release
a bunch of new products including a new
iphone se three new mac models and of
course the ipad air 5. so what i'm going
to be doing in this video is going
through all of the final leaks and
rumors as well as my own reasoning for
why i'm 100 sure we'll be seeing a new
ipad air at this event and then i'll
explain why our ipad air 5 custom
renders have a square camera bump on
them but before i get into all of the
main leaks that really solidify the
rumors of the ipad air coming at next
month's events i want to first go
through the logical and common sense
approach to why it makes sense for it to
come as soon as possible so let's get
right into it last year in september
apple revealed the new ipad mini 6 which
came with a full redesign finally
matching the modern design of the ipad
air and the ipad pro complete with the
usb c port but the thing i didn't expect
apple to do was to go above and beyond
with the new ipad mini specifically by
giving it the brand new a15 bionic chip
instead of sticking to the a14 and the
reason this was so shocking to me was
because the ipad air 4 that is currently
still up for sale comes with the older
a14 chip while actually being a hundred
dollars more expensive than the new mini
with the a15 chip to me this makes
absolutely no sense at all for a less
expensive ipad to come with a newer and
faster chip which puts the entire lineup
into disarray but wait that is not the
only problem the ipad mini 6 has a bunch
of other advantages over the ipad air
like for example it comes with a much
better camera system it actually gets a
flash module while the air does not and
it comes with upgraded video recording
capabilities like getting cinematic
video stabilization at 4k resolution and
it gets extended dynamic range at up to
30 fps while the air doesn't get it at
all but the absolutely biggest
difference is that the new mini comes
with the brand new 12 megapixel ultra
wide selfie camera with features like
lens correction smart hdr3 extended
dynamic range and stabilization which is
a huge step above the basic 7 megapixel
camera on the air and it comes with the
center stage feature for facetime video
and believe it or not even the new
budget ipad for only 329
gets this new 12 megapixel ultrawide
camera as well which makes it even more
obvious that the current ipad air 4
makes literally no sense right now in
the current ipad lineup and on top of
that the new ipad mini 6 actually
supports 5g connectivity which is
obviously extremely important to apple
and the ipad air of course does not have
that right now so in my opinion apple
needs to fix this messed up ipad lineup
asap which is why they absolutely need
to release the ipad air 5 at the next
possible event which should be on march
8th but beyond that there is actually
even more common sense evidence for why
apple should be releasing this ipad air
at their upcoming spring event instead
of later in the year ever since 2019 the
ipad air has been on a 1.5 year release
cycle with the current ipad air 4 being
released in september of 2020 which
would point to a spring 2022 release
date a year and a half later but an even
more important point i want to make is
that the ipad air has never been
released in the middle of the year or in
the summer time and it has also never
been released alongside the ipad pro and
this makes total sense because the ipad
air and the pro are right next to each
other in the lineup currently being
fairly similar in terms of the design
and only a couple of hundred dollars
apart in terms of the price point so it
would kind of create a conflict of
attention but if you've been following
the rumors for the upcoming m2 ipad pro
you'll know that basically all the
rumors are pointing to it coming in the
fall including mark german who is hands
down the most reliable leaker as well as
dylan dkt who said it's coming in the
fall for sure and i personally agree
with this because i believe apple has to
debut the new m2 chip on a mac first
before giving it to the ipad pro later
which is exactly what they did with the
previous m1 ipad pro and finally the
ipad pro has mostly also been on a 1.5
year update cycle just like the ipad air
with the exception of last year with the
whole m1 chip launch and i believe
they're going to go back on that 1.5
year cycle again pointing to a fall
release for the new ipad pro and the
whole point i'm trying to make is that
it means that the ipad air absolutely
needs to get released this spring to
avoid being released alongside the ipad
pro in the fall which apple has never
done before and i don't think they will
so with that said let's move on to all
the latest leaks and rumors that confirm
this theory as well as the new features
and changes that we should expect
but first i've got to show you guys our
new ipad air 5 renders in the green
aluminum finish alongside this beautiful
green wallpaper which you can find a
download link to in the video
description below and yes the design
looks extremely familiar apart from one
noticeable difference the camera bomb
now getting into the leaks for many
months it was believed that the ipad air
would be the first ipad to come with an
oled display but that was apparently
delayed until 2023
according to ross young and shortly
after that major quote agreed and said
that the 2022 ipad air will be sticking
to the same lcd display that we
currently have which is a bit
disappointing but then in july of last
year mac osakara gave us a massive
report in terms of what to expect from
the design and in the report they claim
that the overall design will remain
unchanged with the same 10.9 inch
display and the same touch id power
button but that it would gain a dual
lens camera system with both wide and
ultra wide cameras which is exactly what
we have on the current ipad pro and in
my opinion this makes total sense
because apple's magic keyboard supports
both the ipad air and the ipad pro but
on the air it looks a bit weird because
the singular camera bump doesn't really
fit in the squarish hole in the case and
that is exactly why our new renders come
with a dual lens square bump complete
with a flash and a microphone hole
perfectly matching the iphone 13 camera
bump design and you might also notice
that the lidar scanner is missing
because mac otakara couldn't confirm if
it was coming or not and i think it
makes sense to keep it exclusive to the
ipad pro models for at least another
year now apart from that they also
believe that the new ipad air will get a
four speaker audio system instead of the
current two speaker system and this
makes total sense to me because it
already has the four speaker grilles and
it's expected to slowly gain ipad pro
features over the years they also
believe that it'll get an upgrade to the
a15 chip which is a very obvious change
that i can guarantee will happen along
with everything else that the ipad mini
received last year like optional 5g
connectivity camera performance updates
and of course the new 12 megapixel ultra
wide selfie camera but other than that i
honestly don't think it'll be getting
anything else with the three major
feature changes being the new squarish
camera bump the a15 chip and the quad
stereo speakers which is why i believe
it'll still be carrying the same price
of
599 dollars as the current model is and
now finally let's finish off with the
major leaks that confirm that the ipad
air will be revealed at apple's spring
event last month apple registered new
ipad model numbers with the eec that are
likely for the new ipad air 5 and mark
gurman basically confirmed this recently
by flat out saying that apple plans to
unveil the new ipad air at the march 8th
event which is the biggest confirmation
yet and mac atakara also came back and
even confirmed that the new ipad air
models have actually entered mass
production ahead of the event so if we
combine all of those leaks alongside the
fact that the ipad air desperately needs
an update in order to make it make sense
within the ipad lineup as well as being
on a 1.5 year update cycle i can
confidently say that the ipad air will
be revealed at apple's upcoming spring
event 100 confirmed no doubt about it
now if you disagree with me then go
ahead and let me know in the comment
section below but if you enjoyed this
video click that circle about to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and check out that video which talks
about the max that we're expecting at
the march event thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]